game of thrones season 7 finally
confirmed
one of the biggest secrets in the series
the father of jon snow
is rhaegar targaryen rhaegar died some
15 years before the main story but he's
an important and mysterious
character connected to prophecy and
political plots
with complex relationships with lyanna
stark
and elia martell rhaegar's actions shape
the course of the story
with the fall of house targaryen in
robert's rebellion and the birth of jon
snow
to the fate of westeros in its fight
against darkness
so let's work out who rhaegar was and
what he means for the future
of thrones before tommen and joffrey and
robert the king of westeros was aerys
targaryen
prince rhaegar was aerys son and heir
and he was the brother of daenerys and
viserys
rhaegar was married to elia martell the
sister of ober
and iran and they had two young children
rhaenys and aegon but one day at a
tournament at harrenhal rhaegar passed
over his wife elia and crowned lyanna
stark
the sister of ned stark as rhaegar's
queen of love and beauty
when lyanna was promised to marry robert
baratheon
so the baratheons starks and martels
were mad about this and the next year
things got worse when rhaegar ran off
with lyanna
and robert started a war to get her back
king aerys was killed by jaime lannister
daenerys and viserys fled
east elliot rhaenys and aegon were
killed by the mountain and armory lodge
lyanna died giving birth to jon snow
and rhaegar was killed in battle by
robert
the targaryen dynasty who had ruled
westeros for hundreds of years
was over robert baratheon became the new
king
15 years later the first book begins and
it's a mystery exactly
what happened with rhaegar and lyanna
king robert says that rhaegar abducted
and raped lyanna but in season 7 we
learned that that's a lie
and that rhaegar and lyanna were in love
there's this whole thing in the books
hinting that lyanna rode in the
harrenhal tournament
in disguise as a mystery night and
rhaegar was sent to go find her which
was probably how they met
so they fell in love secretly got
married and ran away to this tower in
dawn to have sex all day until rhaegar
was forced to the war with
robert where he died with lyanna's name
on his lips
while lyanna died in childbirth it's a
tragic love story
but it's also something more complicated
because rhaegar risked everything with
lyanna he not only left his wife and
children he started a war that destroyed
his family and his kingdom and his life
and the reasons behind this go deep into
politics and prophecy
and the fate of westeros when rhaegar
took lyanna he
knew he was risking conflict like we're
told in the show that the war was built
on this lie that rhaegar kidnapped
lyanna
but even if people knew the truth that
lyanna loved rhaegar
they'd still be mad because this was not
a society that let women choose who they
could love
lyanna was a political tool that the
baratheons and starks were using to
build a marriage alliance
by taking lyanna rhaegar ruined those
plans
he also insulted dorne by rejecting his
wife elia
so rhaegar had pissed off three of the
most powerful families in the realm
which is never a good idea but it was
especially dangerous
at that time the political situation was
super delicate because the king
aerys targaryen was insane by the time
of the tourney at harrenhal it was well
known that aerys was mad
he was violent and paranoid obsessed
with fire
burning alive people he thought were his
enemies
he was a terrible king and lots of
powerful people wanted him gone
tywin lannister had beef with aerys and
said he'd prefer rhaegar as king
it's hinted that the baratheons starks
aarons and tullys were forming an
alliance against aerys
marrying lyanna was part of that and
rhaegar himself was apparently plotting
against his father
we're told that the whole tourney of
harrenhal began as a plot so rhaegar
could conspire with the great houses to
force his dad into retirement so rhaegar
was playing the political game
he knew how dangerous things were and he
was carefully scheming to work with the
houses to peacefully replace the mad
king
until he suddenly threw that all away by
publicly crowning lyanna
insulting the very families who could
have been allies against aerys
then by running off with lyanna he set
off the chain of events causing war
the starks came angry to king's landing
the mad king
killed those starks and demanded the
heads of robert annette
that was when the war began and it
didn't seem to have much to do
with the lie of an abduction it was
caused by the tension between king aerys
and the great houses
which rhaegar not only failed to fix but
made
much worse by taking lyanna why did
rhaegar take such a terrible risk at
such a dangerous time
to understand why we need to understand
rhaegar from the very
beginning we're told that rhaegar was
good at everything that he did
he was smart and a great warrior he
played the harp he was beautiful
he was able determined deliberate
dutiful and single-minded
jorah calls rhaegar the last dragon and
says he fought valiantly
nobly and honorably before he died
cersei as a child had a big crush on
rhaegar and hoped to marry him
john connington also loves rhaegar his
silver prince
and rhaegar was popular with the common
people who cheered him at tournaments
so on the surface rhaegar seems like a
golden boy who everyone loved
but barristan says that no one truly
knew
rhaegar he had a private secretive side
a melancholy
and a sense of doom which was related to
rhaegar's birth
at summerhall summerhall was a targaryen
palace in the south
rhaegar's great-grandfather king aegon v
brought his family there to celebrate
the impending birth of rhaegar
but aegon also apparently tried to
perform a fiery magic ritual to hatch
some dragon eggs and the fire got out of
control
and killed king aegon and much of his
family it was during this tragedy at
summerhall
amongst the flames the raela targaryen
gave birth to rhaegar
he was born in grief and that shadow
hung over him all his days
but it wasn't just grief that haunted
rhaegar it was destiny
the targaryens have always been guided
by visions and prophecy
the reason they survived the doom and
came to westeros in the first place was
because of the vision of rhaegar's
ancestor denise the dreamer
we see daeron and damon blackfire having
prophetic dreams in dunk and egg
and prophecy is the reason why rhaegar
was born
his parents aerys and raela got married
because a witch said that the prince
that was promised would be born of their
line
the prince that was promised or azor
ahai is a hero prophesied to be reborn
and save the world from darkness
which seems to mean they'll fight the
white walkers the prophecy is
vague and complex and people interpret
it in different ways
melisandre for instance thinks stannis
baratheon is azor ahai
which doesn't work out while others
think daenerys is the hero
rhaegar was also into this prophecy and
it guided him from a very young age
as a boy rhaegar wasn't interested in
playing with other kids
he just wanted to read books until one
day rhaegar read about azor ahai and
came to believe that he
was the prophesied hero so young rhaegar
went to the master at arms and said he
needed a sword
it seems i must be a warrior he said he
talked about this
in letters with his great grand uncle
maester aemon
aemon agreed that rhaegar was azor ahai
because according to prophecy azor ahai
will be
reborn amidst smoke and salt they
thought the smoke was from the fire that
burned summerhall when rhaegar was born
and the salt was from the tears that
were shed there
so rhaegar was convinced that he was
azor ahai and since azor ahai is
described as a warrior of fire who will
lead the fight against the dark
rhaegar trained and became a great
fighter from a young age
rhaegar was willing to shape his life
around fulfilling the prophecy of azor
ahai
but his beliefs about that prophecy
later changed
aemon says rhaegar came to believe that
azor ahai was not rhaegar but rhaegar's
son
aegon the baby he had with elia because
the prophecy says that azor ahai will be
born beneath a bleeding star
and rhaegar and aemon thought that this
star was a comet that was seen the night
aegon was conceived
this connects to a vision that daenerys
has in book two
she sees her brother rhaegar and his
wife elia with their baby aegon
rhaegar says aegon is the prince that
was promised and
there must be one more the dragon has
three heads
it's not clear how the heads of the
dragon relate to the prophecy of azor
ahai
but the heads do connect to the
symbolism of rhaegar's family the
targaryens
because their banner shows a dragon with
three heads
which represents the three siblings who
led the house 300 years ago
aegon rhaenys and visenya as daenerys
points out these names connect to the
names of rhaegar's children aegon and
rhaenys
so when rhaegar says there must be one
more it sounds like
rhaegar wants a third child called
visenya to complete the set of the
dragon with three heads
but there was a problem because
rhaegar's wife elia was always frail
and sickly and after giving birth to
aegon she couldn't bear any more
children
so if rhaegar believed there must be one
more he'd need
another woman to produce his third child
and that is where lyanna stark comes in
it seems likely that part of the reason
why rhaegar ran off with lyanna and
father jon snow was that he wanted a
third child
to fit the three heads of the dragon if
he was planning for a daughter called
visenya to fit aegon's sisters that
didn't work out but he might have
changed his mind about aegon and decided
that this third child
jon would be azor ahai because rhaegar
says that azor ahai is connected to
something called the song of ice and
fire
which happens to be the title of the
book series lyanna stark of winterfell
is connected to ice
and rhaegar of the targaryen dragonlords
is connected to fire
so a child of lyanna and rhaegar would
be a song or a
son of ice and fire there are
many hints in the books that jon may be
azor ahai
melisandre prays for a glimpse of azor
ahai and her god
shows her jon there's smoke and salt and
a bloody star on the scene where jon
dies and ned promised to protect jon
making jon a prince that was literally
promised so john not aegon or rhaegar
may be
the true hero it might have been lyanna
who realized this in the end
maybe she named john aegon in the show
what better name for the prince that was
promised
so it seems that in the end rhaegar
achieved his goal
his actions with lyanna led to the birth
of jon
who may be the hero who'll save the
world
but does that really justify rhaegar's
actions
couldn't he find a way to father jon
without abandoning his family and
causing a war that killed
thousands how could he be certain that
taking lyanna was the only way
vague prophecy seems like a convenient
excuse for rhaegar to do things that he
probably wanted to do
anyway like ignoring difficult political
realities
running away from his problems and
shacking up with a teenager
because remember lyanna was just 15 in
the books while rhaegar was a
20-something-year-old prince
you can imagine his pitch to her like
hey i'm married and you're engaged but
if we don't bang
the world will literally end and did i
mention i play the harp
and he takes her away to this tower he
calls the tower of joy
and they sit around making prophecy
babies for like a year meanwhile the
world is burning
are these really the actions of a hero
trying to save the world
or was rhaegar just a selfish idiot who
killed thousands because he was thinking
with his dick
there is one theory that ties things
together in a way that could justify
all of rhaegar's actions including the
war and the deaths
because part of the prophecy of azor
ahai is that the hero will have a
burning sword
called lightbringer in book 2 we're told
a story of how the original sword was
forged
apparently azor ahai tried three times
the first sword broke when he tempered
it in water the second sword broke when
he tempered it by stabbing the heart of
a lion
for the third sword he tempered by
stabbing the heart
of his beloved wife she cried with
anguish and ecstasy and died but her
strength went into the steel
and that is how the true lightbringer
was forged and the world was saved
some readers have noticed that this
story kind of mirrors the story of
rhaegar
like azor ahai he tried three times to
fulfill prophecy
first he believed that he himself was
azor ahai but he ended up dying in the
waters of the river trident
second rhaegar believed that his son
aegon would be azor ahai
but aegon was killed in the war by the
men of the lion of lannister
taiwan the third and final time rhaegar
made a child with his beloved wife
lyanna
he plunged his sword into her conceiving
jon
and she died in childbirth so the first
sword broke in water is rhaegar the
second sword broke with a lion is aegon
and the third sword the true
lightbringer forged with the death of a
beloved wife
is jon snow the sword in the darkness
the light that brings the dawn so while
jon
is the weapon who'll beat the white
walkers the actual hero azor ahai
is rhaegar dead years before the story
even starts this theory suggests that
each of these deaths everything that
happened was
necessary pre-destined to save the world
lyanna needed to die in childbirth aegon
needed to die
in the war and rhaegar needed to die at
the trident
maybe he knew maybe rhaegar saw this
stuff in dreams like
his targaryen ancestors did and part of
him
knew that his fate was to die and caused
the deaths of
everyone he loved and that's why he
could never be happy
never be known or fully love or explain
himself to anyone
that was his melancholy his sense of
doom
maybe his is the song of ice and fire
and from the beginning he knew how it
ends that's one theory anyway
there's still lots that we don't know
about rhaegar's goals the politics
prophecy heads of the dragon
and about lyanna and elia like how did
ellia feel about her husband running off
with another woman
was she in on the prophecy stuff and how
much did lyanna know
between lyanna and elia and rhaegar's
mother raela there are a lot of women in
this story whose only role is to be
pretty give birth
then die we know almost nothing about
them so it'd be nice to learn some more
about their stories
what is clear is that rhaegar and his
legacy are tied to the fate of westeros
and will keep seeing his influence until
the end
alt shift x now has a website at old
shift x dot tv
we made it with our sponsor squarespace
which is an amazingly
quick and easy way to make a beautiful
website there's no mucking around with
html or xml and patches and updates you
just choose your domain name pick a nice
template customize it how you like and
you got a website
so if you've got a project or a business
or a theory about how the mountain is
actually podrick on hot pie's shoulders
make it happen using squarespace.com alt
shift x for ten percent off your site
the links below thanks for watching lots
of the ideas in this video are from the
game of thrones community online
so check out the posts and essays linked
below thanks to the patrons
including dillon geekerzoid senia
kalanina thor alexander almelid leia
blaise fairy queen aspen bjerk simon
pollock reindeer prince david oakland
and black clover cheers
you